Every year, Oxford Dictionary puts out a word of the year.
The word of the year for 2016 was this,
post-truth.
It's an adjective it's defined as relating to or
denoting circumstances in which objective facts are less influential
in shaping public opinion than appeals to emotion and
personal belief so in other words post-truth means that
you don't really need to worry about objective facts and it's really about how you
feel about something. You don't have to necessarily agree with objective truth,
but your own subjective truth is much more valuable.
Essentially, this is the word of the year and this is exactly what we're up against
or what our students are up against every day that they walk into the classroom at
school, every day that they interact with their friends and they see media and
movies and music and everything else that's on TV.
This is what we're talking about.
It's essentially relativism, the idea that objective truth no longer
matters. It no longer has any space in our heads to navigate our own reality.
In other words, if I don't like objective reality, I can just completely ignore it
and not worry about it and create my own reality, my own truth.
And you can probably already start to imagine what kind of problems this is going
to cause in your own mind against with students, which is also often why we as
leaders will stand in front of our students and start talking about something that
we think and we know is objectively true, especially what's based on Scripture.
And there's a wall between what we're saying and our students,
because oftentimes they're looking at what we're saying and thinking, well, wait a
minute, that's what you think to be true.
I don't accept that as true. Even though we're saying that this is objectively
true, that this is absolutely true, they don't necessarily agree with it.
See, you and I probably accepted truth for what it is, even if we didn't
like it. So okay, this is what truth is, this is the reality of the situation or the
reality of our environment or the reality of our lives.
We may not like it but we accept it and we deal with it or we change it or whatever.
Students will base their truth off of a reality that they create because
they're told that's exactly what you're allowed to do.
But it's important that you help your students see truth for
what it really is. This lesson is so, so important as you continue to move
forward. Because you can't talk about the reality of the, or the authority of
Scripture. You can't talk about the reality of the resurrection.
You can't talk about the existence of God.
You can't talk about the problem of evil.
You can't talk about really anything else that you're going to dive into until your
students understand the nature of truth.
So truth is what corresponds with reality.
When you think of truth and when you help your students think of truth, sort of help
them navigate away from this idea of post-truth and remind them that truth is
what is real. It's what is reality.
So reality is really a thing that's independent of me or you or your students.
It is what it is regardless if we're interacting with it or not, okay?
So more than just understanding truth and reality is the understanding that genuine
freedom comes by living through truth.
Because remember, we're talking about what it means to have faith.
We're talking about truth in that context.
And our students want to be free.
We want them to experience the freedom that is in Christ.
And that comes from understanding what truth is.
And truth is what corresponds with reality.
Now, it might be really tempting for them to think, well, as long as it makes sense
or as long as it's practical, then that's fine.
Then it can be true, right? It can be coherent.
It can be practical. It can be whatever.
As long as it makes sense to me, then it can be true.
Well, that's not necessarily the case.
And if you think about it, there's lots of things that are coherent.
Think about belief in things like Santa Claus or the Easter Bunny or the Tooth
Fairy. When we're kids, those things make all the sense in the world.
But we know these things don't line up with reality.
And parents may spend a lot of time making these things incredibly practical,
but yet they don't line up with reality.
And so it might make sense for some other religious beliefs or some other ideas that
students may come across that sound good, sound like they make sense, sound very
practical. That doesn't mean they line up with reality.
You know, it might sound really nice to say all religions lead to the same place or
that all religions have some idea of truth to them.
But then what do we do in John 14 when Jesus says, I am the way of the truth and the
life. Nobody gets the Father but by me.
Jesus is making an objective truth claim.
So either that is true or it's not.
And it doesn't matter what I think of it.
So either what Jesus said is true or not, whether I interact with it or not,
whether I believe in it or not, it's either true or it's false.
That's what we call objective truth.
So if what Jesus is saying is true, that makes every other belief that
contradicts belief in Jesus to be false.
So we want our students to be able to see that truth is so critically
important to furthering their discussions on what it means to
believe in Christianity so students in small group are going to have a really good
chance this week to discuss and explore how truth opens the door
to a life of freedom because really when we boil this down is
understanding truth is more than just sort of intellectually understanding what
truth is it's understanding it so that it leads them to freedom
that they can be in Christ and they can live the life that God has purposed for
them. So when we're thinking about truth, there's two kinds of truth that we're
really talking about. Now I've talked a lot about the idea of objective truth, but
there's also something we call subjective truth.
So there's objective and subjective.
Well, what's the difference? And oftentimes this is where our view of truth gets
sort of confused because we mix these two up.
So helping to understand these on your end as well as helping your students to
understand this is going to be one of those things that's going to help take that
wall that's dividing you and your students down to help them see exactly what it is
that you're saying when you're talking about Scripture.
So first, let's talk about the idea of subjective truth.
Well, what is the idea of subjective truth?
Well, if I say something like, I love mint chocolate chip ice cream,
okay? But you like another flavor, chocolate, let's say.
Is it true that I think mint chocolate chip ice cream
is the best kind of ice cream well of course it's true because I think it
and is it true at the same time that if you think chocolate ice cream is the best
kind of ice cream that that is in fact a true statement well of course it's a true
statement because you think it see these are subjective truth statements they're
true because they're based on my experience and my experience only
so it doesn't matter and two different things can be both equally true at the same
time two different flavors of ice cream can be both true at the exact same time
because it's completely subjective and if I'm not here to say it then this truth
statement doesn't matter anymore so it's completely subjective on the other side is
an idea of objective truth.
Now, objective truth has to do with the object.
So if you think of it this way, subject, object.
Truth statement is about the subject here.
Truth statement is about the object here.
Okay? So if I'm talking about ice cream, I'm talking about how I
feel about the ice cream but here if i'm talking about something like my shirt if
i told you that my shirt was blue you tell me i'm wrong well why because my shirt
isn't blue my shirt is green until my shirt is black or white or anything but the
color that my shirt actually is that i'm wrong it's completely independent of my
opinion it's completely independent of my experience.
Even if I never bought the shirt and it's still on the rack at the store, the shirt
is still the color that it is until it ceases to be that shirt in that color.
So it doesn't matter. So it's based on the object, my shirt, not my opinion.
This is based on my opinion. I'm the subject.
So that's kind of the distinguishing feature.
The problem is, is that what we do is we lump religion over here
and we lump Jesus on the side of subjective truth and
we say that well I can believe in Jesus subjectively because based on my experience
I think it's true and it doesn't matter what anybody else thinks and it doesn't
matter if you disagree because somebody else can believe in something completely
different and it'd be equally true but now we go back to John 14.
Jesus said something that is independent of me.
He said something that is an objective truth statement, whether it's true or not.
So that puts belief in Jesus on the objective side.
So when we're talking about Jesus, we're talking about Christianity.
We're talking about the way in which the world works and God being creator and all
the things that we're going to talk about for the rest of the year.
We're talking about objective truth statements.
They're either true or they're not.
And we have to make sure our students understand that they're here.
It's not a matter of opinion or experience, it's a matter of reality.
So truth is what corresponds with reality, which then leads
to freedom.
This is what we want our students to see primarily this week, is that understanding
objective truth, understanding that truth is often objective, understanding that
belief in Jesus is objective.
It is how it corresponds and lines up with reality, and understanding those things
is what's gonna lead your students to the feeling and the understanding and the
experience of genuine freedom in Christ.